from the lord of the rings to stranger
things baslerman's elvis is full of
actors that you know you've seen before
somewhere tom hanks may be the biggest
name but odds are you'll recognize the
others here's everywhere you might have
seen the cast of elvis
tom hanks is a man who needs no
introduction but his character in elvis
might colonel tom parker was a music
promoter who worked with some of the
biggest names in country music before
stumbling across the path of a young
elvis presley in 1955 parker began
managing elvis musical career and helped
him negotiate a new deal with the record
label rca parker continued to act as
elvis manager until the singer died in
1977 and his character in baslerman's
biopic acts as a sort of guide for the
audience leading viewers through the
king's life story i wish to promote you
mr presley hanks of course has extensive
experience not just as an actor but as
someone responsible for bringing
historical figures to life on the big
screen his career is littered with films
based on real events like apollo 13
saving mr banks and the post he's also
taken on more focused memoir-esque
projects like charlie wilson's war
captain phillips and sully he's the
perfect actor to embody colonel tom
parker and his committed performance
helps to ground the film while elevating
it to an entirely new level
austin butler's acting career began when
he was still a teenager mid-2000s kids
probably caught some of his earliest
appearances butler had roles on shows
like ned's declassified school survival
guide hannah montana icarly and zoe 101
he continued to focus on tv appearances
for years showing up on popular series
like switched at birth and arrow if you
don't recognize him from his time on the
small screen you might be more familiar
with his recent film endeavors 2019 in
particular was a big year for butler who
had roles in the dead don't die and once
upon a time in hollywood playing elvis
is a huge role for butler and while
making the film he felt the pressure of
trying to accurately capture the king's
personality the pressure reached its
peak as the actor told the latch when
elvis ex-wife priscilla presley sat down
to watch the film he revealed i was more
nervous than ever when i found out she
was going to sit down in the theater and
finally see it luckily she loved the
film and tweeted about butler's
mesmerizing performance he melts into
his role as the king in a way that any
actor would envy and that every audience
member will likely appreciate
olivia deyoung plays a central role in
elvis starring as priscilla presley the
presleys were married from 1967 to 1973
divorcing just four years before elvis
death deyong is a relatively new face
with just over a dozen acting credits to
her name her big screen roles have come
in films like josie and jack stray dolls
and undertow but she's also had some
highly successful tv gigs in 2019 she
starred as l tompkins on the netflix
series the society just before the elvis
premiere de young played caitlyn atwater
in hbo's critically acclaimed miniseries
the staircase
twenty-seven-year-old daker montgomery
plays steve binder binder is a famed
director and producer whose
collaboration with elvis in the late
1960s resulted in one of the most
important moments in rock and roll
history the two of them worked on what
is now known as the 68 comeback special
the special taped and released in 1968
featured elvis performing at his
absolute best and is one of the standout
moments of his career i knew he had
magic i knew he was that incredible
montgomery has had a smattering of roles
over the past decade some sci-fi fans
might recognize him as the red ranger
from 2017's power rangers an ill-fated
update of a classic children's tv show
more than likely however people will
recognize montgomery from his role in
stranger things as billy hargrove a
vicious bully and the older stepbrother
of max mayfield
people have a real fascination with
celebrity love lives and elvis dives
head first into the rock star's various
relationships natasha bassett portrays
dixie locke elvis's first girlfriend the
two began dating in 1954 just before his
singing career began and they stayed
together until 1956. the tension between
elvis's growing career and his
relationship with locke is a source of
conflict in the film by the time the two
of them split up elvis had become a
global sensation who spent little of his
time back home previously bassett has
starred in polarizing movies that split
the opinions of critics and audiences
her 2016 film katy says goodbye failed
to make an impact with the critics but
audiences highly approved of the film
bassett did it again in 2020 with the
pale door in the lead-up to its release
elvis already secured critical approval
and there's little doubt that general
audiences will be thrilled with the film
elvis didn't build his career entirely
on his own he had the help of other
musicians mentors and talent managers
like jerry shilling elvis and schilling
first met when they were just kids
schilling was never elvis's official
manager but the two collaborated for the
first 20 years of elvis career in baz
lerman's biopic schilling is portrayed
by australian actor luke bracey who's
made frequent appearances in action
flicks and the occasional romantic
comedy throughout his career bracy's
third feature film role was in 2013's gi
joe retaliation as cobra commander since
then bracy has shown up in films like
the november man and hacksaw ridge he
also had the unenviable job of filling
in keanu reeves shoes in the critically
maligned point break remake and his
performance was arguably the highlight
of the film on the romantic comedy front
bracey had the opportunity to co-star
with james marston in 2014's the best of
me and he worked with writer director
max landis on me him her in 2015.
elvis might be the namesake of baz
luhrmann's film but he's far from the
only artist who's featured in the story
elvis himself had the opportunity to
perform alongside some of the greatest
musicians of his entire generation and
the movie highlights a few of the
artists who influenced the king one such
artist is hank snow a renowned guitarist
and songwriter who was inducted into the
country music hall of fame in 1979 david
wenham plays the country music legend in
elvis whenum is no stranger to lerman's
style the two worked together previously
on 2001's moulin rouge and 2008's
australia newbies to lerman's work
probably still recognize wenham from his
role as feramir in the lord of the rings
trilogy or his time helping hugh jackman
slay vampires in van helsing wenham also
has some experience portraying
historical figures he played delios in
zack snyder's 300 and its sequel
throughout his life elvis maintained a
very close relationship with his father
vernon presley and the two of them would
even frequently travel together on tour
after elvis tragic death in 1977 his
father became the executor of his estate
acting in that role until his own death
in 1979 casting presley and his wife
gladys who died in the early years of
elvis's career proved to be difficult in
fact lerman had to recast the roles
after pandemic related delays changed
the production schedule like his co-star
david wenham richard roxborough has a
history with lerman that runs all the
way back to moulin rouge roxburgh also
has van helsing in common with wenham
wenham wasn't the only familiar face on
set for roxboro as he also previously
worked with elvis star luke bracey on
mel gibson's hacksaw ridge and tv buffs
may have caught roxborough on recent
shows like the hunting catherine the
great and the crown
elvis had the opportunity to know and
perform with some musical legends like
hank snow but he had even more time to
develop his skills with his
contemporaries like snow's son jimmy
roger snow he is one of the many elvis
contemporaries featured in baslerman's
biopic in the film snow is portrayed by
cody smith mcphee who is recognizable to
film fans of all stripes at age 13 smit
mcphee starred as boy in john hillcote's
adaptation of cormac mccarthy's the road
the young actor went on to join the
superhero world as nightcrawler in
several of the x-men films that put smit
mcphee in front of a huge audience but
another film cemented his reputation as
a young star to watch he was nominated
for an oscar for best supporting actor
after playing peter gordon in jane
campion's stunning film the power of the
dog smit mcphee brings an understated
brilliance to all his roles and he's
done the same with his performance as
hank snow's son
xavier samuel plays another elvis
contemporary scotty moore elvis history
with more goes all the way back to the
beginning of his career when moore's
band auditioned elvis on behalf of sun
records label owner sam phillips in 1954
at the time moore said he wasn't overly
impressed with elvis though he admitted
the young man had a nice voice however
the two went on to play together for
years and more played a big part in
creating the king's iconic sound samuel
is probably best known for his work in
the twilight series he played riley an
evil vampire created by victoria in her
attempt to raise an army of newborns to
fight the cullens samuel has even more
experience with movie monsters based on
fictional classics in 2015 he starred in
frankenstein a modern retelling of the
gothic tale even more recently samuel
had a role on the amazon prime series
tell me your secrets which was a major
bomb with critics but has overwhelming
support from audiences hopefully
audiences will be just as pleased with
his portrayal of one of the greatest
guitarists in rock history
it's no secret that elvis was inspired
by black musicians like legendary blues
singer bb king who met the young elvis
on several occasions long after elvis
died king recalled i remember elvis
distinctly because he was handsome and
quiet and polite to a fault the two
didn't have a close relationship by any
means but each left an impact on the
other and they both changed the course
of music history forever they might put
me in jail for walking across the street
but you're a famous white boy calvin
harrison jr plays bb king in elvis and
he's expressed his excitement for
audiences to finally get a chance to see
the film this isn't the first time that
harrison jr has been responsible for
bringing a historical figure to life on
screen he previously played teddy green
in the historically inspired series
godfather of harlem he also starred as
fred hampton in the 2020 film the trial
of the chicago 7.
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you